Welcome back, everybody.
Today we have Allan with us here.
Allan, describe some problems when
you're first working with a framework.
What did you experience?
>> When you're first learning a
framework there's a lot of overhead that
you need to learn that's
specific to the framework.
I mean,
it's not just like learning a language.
Take for example AngularJS.
Even if you are an expert in JavaScript,
you can't start off right off
the bat developing AngularJS.
There's some nuances or a caveats or
things that are done differently
within those different frameworks.
Like for example, AngularJS has
different modules, factories.
It's interesting, for some frameworks,
in order to print, hello world,
to display on a web page,
you need multiple lines of code.
Whereas like if you're just dealing
with straight HTML, CSS and
JavaScript it's pretty simple to do.
>> So for students that are just
starting out into the world of
frameworks and
trying to learn their first one,
what would be some
advice you'd give them?
>> I would say,
first and foremost, you need to be
very comfortable with the language.
Each framework kind of ships,
or usually ships,
with their own DSL or
domain specific language.
But if you don't understand the base
language, you're incurring a lot
of technical debt,
professionally as well as personally.
As far as advice to extend
generally to any framework and
students jumping into it, another thing
I would recommend is definitely do not
be afraid to jump into
the documentation.
It's supposed to be your mainstream or
largely-supported frameworks.
The documentation is excellent.
Take for example,
AngularJS or Ruby on Rails.
You should have that bookmarked and
always, always visit it.
I mean, if the documentation's
good then most of your
questions will be answered there.
>> So you've worked with
a couple of frameworks.
>From learning your first one, what was
it like transitioning to a new one?
>> A good question, so when you're
transitioning frameworks, you don't
lose all the knowledge that you gained
from learning that initial framework.
And part of the value of learning
frameworks is that a lot of the best
practices are kind of built in,
if not forced
on you with configuration,
or with convention, rather.
And so you're able to translate
a lot of those best practices
to other frameworks.
Or even if you don't have a framework,
you can build your application
with some of those best practices that
you learned from previous frameworks.
Okay, so learning your first framework
might be a little tough, but
then the slide is a lot easier for
learning a new one.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of
design patterns that are common
throughout frameworks.
For example, MVC, model-view-controller,
that's something that
exists across most of our front-end
frameworks or our full-side frameworks.
>> Okay, so learning your first
one might be a big push, but
then after that, then it's a lot
easier to switch to a new one and
learn a different style of framework.
>> For sure,
every framework's different.
They all have their different nuances
and caveats, but the general themes and
best practices are pretty
consistent across all of them.